Hallo liebe Fans von easy German zurück aus
Berlin mit einer kurzen Ankündigung heute
erinnert ihr euch, wir haben den Oktober
zum easy german Monat erklärt und ja wir
haben jeden Tag ein Video gepostet es war
viel Arbeit aber es hat so viel Spaß gemacht das
wir wollen  um dies weiter zu tun und das ist
unsere ankündigung für heute ab heute
eigentlich seit letztem monat werden wir weiterhin
pro woche pro tag ein video mit leichtem deutsch produzieren
und bitten dich
dafür um deine unterstützung und du hast
uns in den vergangenen wochen bereits enorm geholfen
und Monat durch die Patreon-Community ist
Patreon zu einem unglaublich hilfreichen
Tool für uns geworden, das uns dabei hilft, weniger
zu wissen, wie wir zum Beispiel unser Studio finanzieren
, unsere Kameraausrüstung mieten, und wir
möchten Sie einladen, sich uns auf Patreon anzuschließen,
Sie können uns einfach beitreten
indem Sie uns zum Beispiel mit einem Dollar pro Tag unterstützen
und dieser Dollar wird vollständig
in unsere Produktion investiert und wir haben auch einen
extra für Sie, wie Sie wissen
, haben wir jeden Tag ein kleines Extra in den Videos
und deshalb nehmen wir nicht das ganze Filmmaterial auf,
wir haben einige Outtakes, und das ist auch ein
Goodie, das wir unserer Patreon-Community geben wollen,
also bald auf Patreon, tatsächlich
ab dieser Woche finden Sie dort zusätzliches
Bonusmaterial und das ist für Sie als  eine
Möglichkeit, Danke zu sagen, vielen Dank, dass Sie
uns unterstützen, und bleiben Sie dran für ein
deutsches Video pro Tag